foreign
let's go to one of our most trusted news
sources shall we uh it's a Slayer a true
Slayer of Miss dis and Mal information
yep who's this gonna be um upholder of
Truth Liberty and apple pie I imagine I
mean it being apple pie with just a hint
of mattress just a hint of atrocene
because it's got wheat it's probably got
some corn if you it's got apples I don't
know if you were allowed to use it on
apples but you're allowed to use it on
corn and wheat so and they do I am
talking of course about the New York
Times Yes
um this week
man
New York Times this week the New York
Times published a yet another hit piece
on RFK okay five noteworthy falsehoods
Robert F Kennedy Jr has promoted
a long time vaccine skeptic Mr Kennedy
is leading heavily on misinformation as
he mounts a long shot 2024 campaign
thank you New York Times for protecting
us from his misinformation there are
five falsehoods that they talk about in
this article
we could talk about all of them we're
just going to talk about the one that's
relevant to what I'm talking about today
right so we go down too he has made
baseless claims about a connection
between gender dysphoria and chemical
exposure
in an interview last month with Jordan
Peterson a conservative Canadian
psychologist and public speaker Mr
Kennedy falsely linked chemicals present
in water sources to transgender identity
a lot of the problems he had said we see
in kids particularly boys it's probably
underappreciated how much of that is
coming from chemical exposures including
a lot of sexual dysphoria that we're
seeing he said he referred to research
on an herbicide atrocene in which
scientists found that quote it induces
complete feminization and chemical
castration in certain frogs yes it does
but the New York Times continues no
evidence exists to indicate that the
chemical typically used on farms to kill
weeds causes the same effect in humans
let alone gender dysphoria and according
to the Centers for Disease Control and
prevention quote most people are not
exposed to atracine on a regular basis
while we know for sure that the CDC is
either just wrong or flat out lying and
with regard to the research that does
not exist no evidence exists to indicate
that the chemical typically used on
farms to kill weeds cause the same
effect in humans well let's just see
about that shall we
my God okay so
I simply did a search on Google Scholar
for atrocene human health effects
I got many thousands of hits many many
thousands of hits
one typical paper
and I'm I will go to the site here in a
minute but um and I'll post this but one
typical paper finds that sure there are
some concerning cancers and
endocrinological effects that some
research is found to be associated with
after seeing yeah but it's really not
that bad after seeing disappears really
quickly from the environment and from
you and the research wasn't as strong as
it seems anyway signed yours truly I kid
you not the Society of chemical industry
that is who is putting out this this
work okay so here it is uh this is this
is published in the journal Pest
Management science okay Pest Management
science which I don't know if I can zoom
in here really well but you will see
that their tagline is where science
meets business
that is literally the tagline of the
journal where this piece of garbage
research was published okay so give me
my screen back here for just a minute
Zach well I find oh no here we go uh so
here it is here is their site the
society
um for whatever whatever I called it
Pest Management science is the
international Journal of research and
development and crop protection and Pest
Control look at that Banner look at that
Banner are you interested in receiving
this SEI Journal you too can have your
crops sprayed with a crop duster and
everyone will be happy and dead in no
time there's plenty of insecticides out
there most of what we're talking about
is after scene which is an herbicide
um certainly the again this is The Pest
Management the journal is called Pest
Management science it used to be called
that they recently changed the name of
the journal from from two Pest
Management science from pesticide
science they just called it that it was
called pesticide science the journal
published by the Society of chemical
industry whose tagline is literally
where business meets science or was it
where science meets business I don't
know where science business so sorry
um
so it strikes me I don't know anything
about this publication but based on what
you've presented about it it seems like
an analog for the phony fields
surrounding grievance studies right
you've got a bunch of fields that
pretend to be doing science and
revealing new things that we didn't know
about the way humans function and it's
it's what I've called ideal laundering
yep but here you've got business
laundering the dirty details of the
compounds that's pumping into the world
that and their disruptive effect so the
point is okay so industry has created
you know a a nonsense field or the
equivalent in order to make its products
look safe so that people can muddle any
argument that is delivered and you know
they they literally are creating the
journals in which the people whom they
fund can publish scientific research
that comes up with the conclusions that
they need them to come up with in order
to keep dumping and pumping this crap
into the environment that we all share
and we know we know that whoever
controls the Press
controls what is published and in
science whoever controls what is
published controls what research is done
and therefore the New York Times naive
sycophantic Insidious and disgusting
claim that
what do they say exactly
um baseless claims about a connection
between gender dysphoria and chemical
exposure there's no evidence well
there's no evidence in part because the
the places that are publishing any you
know the research that would be relevant
here will not publish such evidence and
it's true I don't I don't find the
absolutely 100 clear research that
demonstrates this connection but then
those people who want to do that
research aren't getting fun day right I
mean it's it's
very much like in say 2022 when we're
beginning to see a few pre-prints and a
few papers that were finding some
problems with the MRNA vaccines for
covid all of which to a paper said but
these vaccines are still the best thing
you can do for covet it's it's it's
don't hurt me walls in a different place
it's it's okay we're still we still
believe what you're telling us but we
did find this one little tiny problem
and that's that's the kind of research
you're going to get in journals like
this
and it has a unfortunate echo in another
place
um to the exact same pattern where
okay here you've got the New York Times
in exactly the place that the people who
used to read the New York you know our
parents who read the New York Times at
the you know the Sunday breakfast table
I
think the New York Times of course but
my point is at some point you start
reading the New York Times and you think
what the [__] is this right but back in
the day before the what the [__] is this
era
um The New York Times would have been
expected to be concerned about
pesticides exactly the food supply in
the in the environment Etc and the ideal
point is that expectation is being
disrupted here by a higher priority
right the corruption of the democratic
party must be maintained against
anything that threatens it and Bobby
Kennedy Jr threatens it and so the point
is the New York Times will now uh
Embrace whatever position undermines
Bobby Kennedy even when his position
would be a traditionally liberal
position so hold on the echo is that
this sounds a lot like Eric topel who
actually fought to delay the release of
the vaccine so that Trump wouldn't get
credit for that right the point is oh
Eric tople who's so very concerned about
people suffering from from covid was
actually cynically delaying this thing
for political reasons here you've got
the New York Times cynically uh
disrupting a obvious argument about the
hazards of pesticides for political
reasons and the point is well is
anything sacred is there any principle
that you will adhere to even when
somebody that you politically fear uh
you know says it right right yeah and
yeah it's it's even worse than that but
I think Zach has something to say yes
well someone in the chat reminded me you
will want to remember dad that Kennedy's
term for these idea laundering
scientists is by altitudes
absolutely it's not science it's paid
they paid service to create a scientific
article for something it is what it is
yeah to create an illusion of science
yes
um
so okay Europe actually banned the
European Union banned actressing back in
2003.
uh that's 20 years ago
and here show my screen uh one more time
here this is a 2006 article
um co-published by a research scientist
and a lawyer European Union bans
atrocene while the United States
negotiates continued use so it was
banned in 2003 this paper is published
in 2006 it begins atrazine is a common
agricultural herbicide with endocrine
disruptor activity they just flatly
state it there is evidence that it
interferes with reproduction and
development and may cause cancer there
is and the industry-sponsored research
says that it's not that important yeah
yeah we don't we don't really think it
matters but um I don't know why
although the U.S Environmental
Protection Agency EPA approved its
continued use in October 2003 of the
same month the European Union announced
a ban of atrocene because if ubiquitous
and unpreventable water contamination
the authors of this paper and I'm not
going to read through all of it but the
authors of this paper reviewed
regulatory procedures and government
documents and Report efforts by the
manufacturer of atracy in syngenta to
influence the U.S atrazine assessment by
submitting flawed scientific data as
evidence of no harm and by meeting
repeatedly and privately with EPA to
negotiate the government's regulatory
approach many of the details of these
negotiations continue to be withheld
from the public despite EPA regulations
and Federal open government laws that
require assessed decisions to be made in
the open
one more little piece from this paper
despite statutory requirements the
agency advisory committees must be
objective and publicly transparent EPA
officials held approximately 50 5-0
private meetings
with syngenta regarding atrazine in 2003
EPA established and utilized two
advisory committees composed only of
Representatives of syngenta and EPA
without any public representation
epa's 2003 approval of atrocene relied
on the final recommendations of these
two committees characterized by EPA as
joint efforts between EPA and sugenta to
determine how atrazine should be
regulated and where it should be
monitored
yeah that so we're
those those of us in the public who
continue to think
that the people whose job title suggests
that they are looking out for us that
they care about public health that they
recognize that their job in public
health is about actually protecting the
Public's Health as opposed to the
profits of Corporations
those people who still believe that need
to wake up
this has been going on for a very long
time
and for a very long time there's been no
one watching out for what's in our food
what's on our crops what's in our water
what's in our air we have the Regulatory
Agencies
but they're doing exactly the opposite
of what they're supposed to be doing
yeah we don't I mean it's a subtle
distinction we don't have the Regulatory
Agencies what we have is something that
has hollowed them out and left them
there so that we don't even you know if
you knew as we know when we travel in
other parts of the world right there's
nothing protecting us we can at least
take some steps to protect ourselves but
when you have something that is
ostensibly doing the job that is
specifically not doing the job in fact
it's doing the inverse of the job
you get the danger of the false sense of
security and the full exposure to this
stuff
[Music]